[Musique]
le travail de toute une année plus de
150 artistes présentent des oeuvres tout
droit sortis de leurs ateliers des
artistes un peu particulier ils sont
tous amateurs et pratique au sein
d'associations billancourt toise on peut
voir donc nos artistes enfants qui
évolue d'année en année qu'on voit
grandir devenir des adolescents
développer leur pratique améliorer leur
technique
et puis apprendre à nos adultes convoi
s'essayer à différentes techniques on
laisse libre cours aux associations
d'exposer leurs artistes
donc ils choisissent ils ne choisissent
pas chaque artiste expose jusqu'à deux
oeuvres ces deux oeuvres sont présentées
telles qu'elles donc on a vraiment pas
de sélection qui est effectué et ça
permet de laisser libre cours aux
artistes et que pouvoir exposer ce qu'il
souhaite
[Musique]
et
des oeuvres personnelles et des heures
ou collective regroupant toutes les
techniques travaillées durant l'année
certains de ces artistes ont attiré le
regard des sélectionneurs d'art talent
le concours d'arts visuels de la commune
la règle en course est un bien universel
ça devrait être partout pareil
d'ailleurs est donc tout le monde doit y
trouver sa place les amateurs comme les
professionnels et ce sont ces amateurs
qui au travers des associations font
vivre et insuffle ce dynamisme la ville
tout en mode année huit associations ont
répondu présentes cette année leurs
adhérents présents près de 200 oeuvres
pour une exposition toute en légèreté
[Musique]